and to be an entrepreneur you know we
came to it later in life I mean I
already had a corporate career and I was
close to 40 when I started Mona
and uh I think that uh it needed to be
there was a really high bar for starting
a company right it needed to be
something we truly cared about welcome
to 20-minute leaders just sit back relax
and learn from the leaders of today it's
a journey each one is different unique
inspiring let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctec
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders today I'm with yotam
Oren the co-founder and CEO of Mona
disclaimer I'm an angel investor in this
startup and Mona is a startup developing
an intelligent monitoring platform for
AI and automations in a variety of
Industries with over 15 years of
experience is it is a technology
executive your time gained extensive
experience bringing data-driven products
into the enterprise software Market
prior to Mona he was a growth and
product executive at ADP and an
associate partner at McKinsey and your
thumb holds a BSC in computer science
from Ben-Gurion University and an MBA
from the University of Michigan
[Music]
it's gonna be a really great
conversation I'm excited to hear your
story the story of Mona the story of
what's happening with AI today the
different opportunities that are
presented as
the whole world is transitioning to to
leverage AI what that means for
organizations what that means
transitioning from research to product
and where you are in all this and where
amona is situated across all of this and
so thank you again for being here you
Tom you have a really interesting
background leading up to your
co-founding of Mona including some
basketball some engineering some
Consulting tell me a little bit about
your journey connecting the dots for me
backwards
some some may say I've been all over the
place
um but I I like to I like to say that
every every step in the way led me to
the next step and and taught me
something new
uh but I I have you know I I have you
know I have um you know in in my
Professional Care post-military Post
University
I've been around data my entire career I
started as a big data engineer
um you know working actually in the
early days of smartphones on bringing
mapping and navigation into into the
handhelds this is before Google Maps you
know was was all over the place and and
free and kind of you know made tools you
know navigation uh software less
you know less uh relevant maybe from
Paid providers and so I was working for
a start that did that for a little bit
um and working with actually big data
problems right I mean you know local Geo
geolocation data was big data back then
we didn't call it that but that's what
it was
and uh and I later
um left engineering and became a
Management Consultant in McKinsey and
you know a lot of people
look at that you know funny a little bit
you know McKinsey Consultants becoming
entrepreneurs
um but you know it's what I love you
know and earnestly about the Consulting
experience that that really set me up
well to be an entrepreneur is that it's
almost like a really fast track to see a
ton of Industries and how things work
and taking things that work well in one
industry and transferring them to
another or finding common themes is
something I'm really passionate about
and tell love which is why I'm you know
later down the line you know years later
a decade later I'm working on this
horizontal platform right it serves
multiple Industries
um but even in McKinsey I was doing a
lot of data work back then in early
2010s we used to call it Big Data
officially and a lot of the questions
were around or we collect all this
operational data or you know a logistics
company or a bank how do we leverage
this data to make better decisions this
was the early days of investing in
machine learnings the infrastructure
wasn't there it was very expensive to
produce models and develop them
most companies did not have an army of
PhD data scientists but we were
definitely a lot there was a lot of talk
about that and it would definitely
headed that in that direction
um and then I I joined Corporate America
and I worked in a fortune
um you know 500 called ADP and the HR
Tech space I actually LED an analytics
team that worked on a recommendation
system of sorts which again
um was in in this early day
um
um I I'd say like less sophisticated or
more traditional uh predictive
capabilities and not as as advanced as
they exist today but first-hand
experience with how challenging it is to
drive adoption of machine learning in
the Enterprise
and then fast forward to today you know
in the last four years with Mona
um with um you know two brilliant
friends and um former Google Engineers
um and you know we're all passionate
about
you know helping organizations with with
this shift and of adopting an eye AI in
a broader scale which I know we'll talk
about
I love it okay well let's let's dive in
tell me about AI in 2022 what's
happening yeah yeah so um it's so much
money has already been poured right
investment has been Sky High but uh most
will agree that
to a large extent the practices become
has remained largely a research-oriented
practice
what I mean by this is that
still uh to what extent we build data
science teams and we hire data
scientists and we tell them your job is
focused on data on understanding
business problems or collecting a lot of
data on a modeling right on creating
models leveraging this data to solve
those business questions
um
um but the end product of your work is a
model and uh and and once you develop a
model and you test it and you you know
you hand it over over this virtual
organizational fence
um and it becomes someone else's problem
and uh this is you know I think that a
lot of the money that's been poured into
AI programs across Industries to date
has been working this way where the data
scientists sent in the lab and they're
building this amazing those amazing
models but the level of adoption in the
organization is still not as high as it
should be
and partially it is because there's
great research but there's no
operational readiness
it's not yet a great product uh cases
now for some generalizing and there are
cases where it succeeded
more and more organizations started
realizing that this is not a way to run
their multi-million dollar AI programs
and they need to start shifting you need
to start thinking about product
discipline about how to adopt more
product oriented thinking into those AI
programs
and um and part of it is about changing
the role of the data science teams
changing the role of the AI teams making
them more like product teams
the rise of machine learning engineering
is it part of this this shift in
transition the rise of this practice
called ml Ops machine learning
operations is part of this which is
about incorporating and introducing
software engineering best practices in
production best practices into AI
um and of course the area we're in
which is called you know monitoring
observability
is an element of this uh transformation
and shift too
and so if we're looking at
monitoring observability
you know in though I I like how you call
it the an intelligent machine learning
monitoring platform
what is what what does this actually
mean why do AI teams need a monitoring
and observability platform
so um let's start with this that with
the fact that um monitoring is a
foundational need because it's part of
uh product discipline right you don't
want your customers being the first ones
to find out that something is is wrong
right now predictive models are
notoriously difficult to test in the lab
you do the best you can to validate to
you put them in the business process in
production and now they serve their
customers and there's you know the
volumes go up Etc
and um but you want to know if something
is if it's working as intended you want
to know if it's working as well as it
should now why do you need intelligent
monitoring so like the fact that you did
monitoring is kind of a given in that
sense right that it serves the business
the business is relying
intelligence a lot of it is because
problems to a large degree in AI start
really small
um and are hidden in plain sight before
they burst into the surface
and when they burst into the surface a
lot could be at risk not just Revenue
left on the table or you know a chat bot
going wrong there's reputational risk
um there might be significant money risk
for example in a credit card uh you know
fraud detection system that processes
billions of dollars right
um and uh and you know every prediction
that goes wrong could be you know
meaningful license to credit card
process or a bank
um and um and and these things are you
know these things are impacting real
people AI is used for Performance
Management the talent it's for
recruiting right to a proven reject um
credit you know loans
um so there's real implications for real
people and you want to know when
something is going wrong
um the key with intelligence is that
problems start really small so you want
to catch them when they're still small
when the impact is not as big
when uh maybe your business kpis haven't
even suffered yet and you can be
proactive in addressing them before you
go through and you really need to be
intelligent because
how do you go slow how do you go right
there's so many ways to slice and dice
um you know credit card transactions
right for example you might have run a
billion a day right how do you how do
you slice and dice how do you find the
pockets where there might be issues
so it definitely is not an easy big
undertake
okay so if we're looking at it from a
product perspective what have you
realized about the different ways that
these AI teams are working
and that you've then tailored your own
solutions to them sort of what is the I
guess the consumer behavior of these
data science teams or these research
teams that you said okay this is sort of
the pattern that we're seeing and this
is how we're going to be shaping our
product to fit their needs
yeah I mean so number one
um they
um need to they want to be independent
um they want to be able to iterate
independently and be less dependent on
other
uh subgroups of teams within their
organization such as devops or other
engineering teams and so it needs to be
tool that they can use
um it needs to be accessible to them
they need to be able to tailor it to
their problem because every AI use case
is a snowflake and has its own unique
characteristics and unique situations
circumstances and so that it needs to be
highly flexible and configurable
um and and if you come in from the
outside
um as a monitoring solution provider and
tell the data scientist I can tell you
if your algorithms are working or not
I they wouldn't believe you right so it
needs to be the tools process the
platform but it needs to be moldable
into working for them and and for what
they need to get out of it
um
and finally
um you know it needs to not dominate
their time right at the end of the day
it needs to benefit the research
it needs to provide them new information
like new insights things they don't
already know or can't know themselves
but this doesn't need to be something
that they spend their entire day in need
to make them more efficient
um you know one an adult that is that
you know the average data science team
will spend a third of their time on
production break fix and like
investigations and and trouble
um and this needs to make to reduce that
time to a minimum right to mix make it
so that they deal they still need to be
accountable and they want to be
accountable for the full life cycle they
want to be accountable for how their
models and research perform in the
business
they don't want to spend their days in
induction drop and you know production
troubleshoot so it needs to be make them
more efficient
and Dot dominate their time
so if we're looking a little bit higher
level at the space that we're in and one
of the things that we very briefly
mentioned before we started the
interview was uh you mentioned this idea
of product oriented AI
which is sort of
in a relatively new thinking or an
evolutionary thinking of within the AI
domain tell me a little bit about what
you meant by that
yeah I mean in a way it's it's um it's a
set of best practices
that organizations are starting to
um adopt
in order to
scale their AI programs the right way
take them out of the lab and put them
into business and make sure that the
business can truly rely on on those on
those AI driven applications now within
product oriented AI what do we actually
mean right
um it means that
there is more end-to-end accountability
four outcomes and that's
um
that the AI team is the one that takes
the account it also means the success
measure success criteria for AI is no
longer just about the upconometry ml
Telemetry things like Precision of
models and recall Etc but also actually
where the business outcomes achieved or
not right that's what the product is all
right that's what it's there for
um and um and I know overall it's just a
better way to run uh your your AI
program if you're a big organization
it's a trend product oriented AI right
it's not some sort of like IP right it's
an end that we see across Industries and
we're trying to organize it and and you
know and call it out
um and um
and it is it doesn't all by the way it
doesn't mean the end of research
it doesn't mean less research or less
investment research in fact teams that
adopt product-oriented AI practices
eventually benefit the research they
become more effective in their research
because that complete life cycle
additional data that you can get from
looking into your you know your full
life cycle and how your AI performs in
business can actually
teach new things to the research right
like add new value and add new insights
into the research roadmap so
um so it's a complementary Trend and
it's it's definitely one that is here to
stay
I think that it's
um also
something that organizing that you know
Executives and sponsors of AI programs
relate to envelopes I think is like is
another term that's very important and
and relevant
um but it is definitely more of an
operational term and more associated
with
essentially adopting engineering and I.T
practices we're Factor oriented AI
wraps around this right and uh and and
it's the way is the way also you bridge
the gap between the AI team and The
Business
where did you develop your own passion
and enthusiasm for for this world it's
not a trivial
um it's not a trivial company for an
entrepreneur to go on a journey
um I I'm just I'm curious where you know
where your own passion came from in
regards to this how did this whole thing
come about
yeah I mean um it's it's it's a number
of things right it's always it's always
um difficult to pinpoint the exact
driver
uh behind band think but but it combines
a few things that I really enjoy number
one I've been around the data industry
so I know it
um and um and I'm a True Believer in the
value that AI can bring to a variety of
Industries
um and you know and really change our
lives in a lot of ways
um and so I'm really excited about being
part of enabling
that you know the like the growth in in
AI in general
um the second thing is that you know
it's a really difficult problem to solve
um because it's a brand new category
because it requires deep technology a
big data system Etc and so that's
more intellectually uh challenging and
and exciting and currently the team I
work with my co-founders they wouldn't
have been willing to take to tackle a a
smaller problem right you needed to be
really big for them to go after
um and um and and I I I I benefit from
this because I get to work with you know
really smart folks on a really difficult
problem so
um so that's that's that's that's
another part of this
um and you know I am I am personally a
data nerd right I love to I love to look
at data I also love the idea that it's
horizontal I mean I know this is like
you know I can add more and more reasons
here right but
um it's I've been horizontal most of my
career and Consulting has been
horizontal I like to work across
Industries I think there's so much to
learn
um when you're not vertically focused
and there's so much to you know to share
across
um and so that's that's beneficial too
and uh you know it'd be an entrepreneur
you know we came to it later in life I
mean I already had a corporate career
and I was close to 40 when I started
Mona
and uh I think that uh it needed to be
there was a really high bar for starting
a company right it needed to be
something we truly cared about to go
after
and so the decision to go and become an
entrepreneur at 40 that that's not a
trivial one
it's not
um and uh believe me I my wife and I had
a lot of conversation you know many
conversations about uh you know whether
to do it or not and whether it was the
right time I think that uh at the end of
the day
you know
um
I uh
I realized when I came to this Crossing
that the fact that I was so excited
about it when I was talking to it about
to it you know about it to her and the
fact that I had all these you know every
everything every aspect of it sounded
really exciting to me
um eventually made it a no-brainer
um on paper I might have been really
difficult to decide to do that
especially
um where you know as you may know and as
an entrepreneur there's often a
financial compromise which you know of
course there was in my case
there's
um you work longer hours you uh you know
you definitely take you know some some
things take a hit some other priorities
but um the level of excitement we had
about this the desire to work with these
people who are also my friends outside
of work I mean
um it really drove it home and made it a
no-brainer
your time best of luck with Mona thank
you so much for the time I I can't wait
to share this with the world and we'll
continue cheering
um and uh thank you very much for being
here with me thank you yes of course
happy happy to have this conversation
[Music]